you might remember the story of the
flagship of the black sea fleet the
russian vessel mokva
we are hearing that it has now sunk this
is from russian state-owned news agency
rear
they say that the moskva
missile cruise ship has now sunk the
very latest breaking news there um
dispute about what actually happened the
ukrainians said they fired two neptune
missiles towards this after distracting
those on board with
a drone
the russians said that ammunition went
on fire and that was the cause of the
issue but we're now hearing from
state-owned russian media that the
vessel the moskva has actually sunk it
is the flagship of the black sea fleet
sank as it was towed back to port we're
told in stormy weather following an
explosion and a fire
the defense ministry had earlier said
that the soviet era ship had been badly
damaged by that fire which as i said
ukraine said was the result of its
missile strike um it was some 40 years
old dated as we said from the soviet era
but had since been refitted
largely a symbolic presence certainly in
the black sea
and uh you know of great celebration you
might imagine to the ukrainian forces
that this has happened the fear of
course was about missile strikes from
the russians towards port cities like
odessa for example so the breaking news
we're getting them is that the moskva
the flagship of russia's black sea fleet
has sunk as it was towed back to port in
stormy weather following an explosion
and a fire disputed caused the
ukrainians certainly suggesting it was
their missiles which caused the damage
no doubt we'll get more reaction to that
a bit later